foreign
[Music]
ER I'm a professor at the University of
California Davis and I'm the director of
The genome Center and what we're going
to discuss today is our rapid wrap-up
ramp up of high throughput testing for
covid and our ongoing deployment of
genotyping for analysis of variants
this has been a massive effort I'm just
a spokesman for many people some of whom
are listed here but our goal has been to
provide rapid and inexpensive High
throughput testing and for variance of
concern using technology that has been
robust technology through teamly
deployed in the AG biotech sector
now much of our philosophy on this has
been based on the fact that
what we need is cheap rapid turnaround
testing
adapted from Michael meaner at Harvard
this curve you can see that the
Infectious period varies five six days
or so and if you were to test that the
when someone's symptomatic it takes you
five or seven days to get the test
results back
that person is no longer infectious and
so much of the early testing really was
uh inconsequential what you need to be
able to do is to catch people at the
front end and uh isolate and do contact
tracing
so then you can focus your resources on
the Infectious individuals with low CT
values
so
I knew that the biotech sector had
technology that would enable High
throughput testing the agbiotech sector
regulate the large companies will
generate millions of data points a day
the middle machine you see in there in
the middle the Nexa is an endpoint High
throughput PCR machine uh we though went
with the intellicue which is the qpcl
platform you see in the left there and
this is
um actually in the agbiotech sector it's
not really even regarded as ultra high
throughput it's just medium throughput
and the way that both these machines
achieve this is that you see on the
right hand side you've got the tape and
it has uh sets of 768 microwells on the
tape and these machines will set up the
reaction and the case of the intellicube
will run the qpcr action on the machine
it's very hands-off so you can basically
basically shut up sequentially many many
reactions
in the early stages of our deployment we
discussed with ag biotech folks
particularly at cortiva and they were
very helpful and I think there are a
number of takeaways that we took from
those discussions one of which is you
need fast actionable data in real time
don't sample more than you need you each
assay is only a very very small amount
you need robust and Technology that's
tolerant of sample engineerty you need
to minimize the number of handling steps
and you need to get the micro plate
format as soon as possible
and
in order to minimize the expense use for
reaction volumes and so this is where
our workflow which developed around
these principles
it was a very fast ramp up we got the
green light from the administration in
early August and they actually told us
they wanted to start testing six weeks
later we actually were running reactions
it took us for another two or three
weeks to get the regulatory environment
a regular paperwork straightened out
running the getting the technology set
up was more was easier than getting all
the regulations which kept on changing
during the time they were deploying this
technology
so initially we screened about a
thousand students as they came onto
campus the first week
two and a half times that the next week
four and a half thousand in the third
week and
now we've expanded to all students back
to the staff and they have to get tested
at least weekly if they're going to come
onto campus and we've also since
expanded to the city of Davis through
the healthy Davis together initiative
now this is a very sort of holistic
approach of which we are only a small
part but an important one so the city
anyone that lives or Works in Davis can
get free testing and they're encouraged
to come in every week
um
the way that this works
is that you make an appointment you get
a QR code
to your phone this idea is checked at
the kiosk the QR code is then linked to
a barcode on the sample tube that you're
given there's absolutely no
identification well there's no Phi
information that comes to the testing
lab
symptomatics for asymptomatics
cinematics are samples elsewhere and
there's a YouTube Limp link if you want
to see more of that home which works
now one of the questions we had is how
do we deploy the sampling and some
consideration of whether to go to sort
of at home uh or collection kits I think
this is much more efficient because you
don't have to make up the kits you don't
have to break them down
we've got one very large collection
kiosk which is a four basketball courts
um 3x bidding stations Works seven days
a week eight hour days we have a
capacity of about 32 000 samples a week
and we've got another one of these
replicated slightly smaller for healthy
Davis together
it takes less than four minutes to get
through the whole system and we have a
very high level of compliance in the uh
the student body and the faculty and
staff
we are a pop-up lab in the genome Center
where a extension of the clear certified
student health lab
and obviously we have MDS in charge at
the top
one of the other important points here
is you've got to have redundancy if
you're running a high throughput
workflow and if we therefore we've got
two intelligubes that you see there
there are a wide variety of parameters
we had to explore and optimize I'm not
going to go through all of this please
take a screenshot and we can discuss
from offline later if you want to go
through them but
there was a a large amount of parameters
that we explored one of the things was
though because the intellicube uh allows
you to do 768 Wells arrays in one and a
half hours we could rapidly explore a
broad experimental space with
replication to optimize the various
parameters
so the workflow we ended up with is
you've got your tube the barcoded it
goes into a 96 well rack in the
collection kiosk then we heat and
activate it to devitalize it and one of
the keys to handling saliva with saliva
direct it's we directly use raw saliva
does anyone to work with saliva nodes
that you get a lot of viscosity issues
the DNA core came up with a great idea
of using papain as you know when you eat
papaya you can feel that your lips
tingle
that's because the the pain is a an
aggressive protease that is doing a
number on your saliva
so incubating with papain really gets
rid of the
um gets rid of all the viscosity of
course you need to heat and activate
that otherwise it'll chew up your pcre
agents
then we semi-automate the decapping and
transfer to 384 well plates we can take
the 384 well plates and put it on the
intellicube and then the intellicube
does everything else it sets up the
reactions and runs them the results are
exported to the cloud where we use Eugen
text fast finder
plugin to do the QC and Reporting
this has a pretty rapid turnaround time
so we can run 768 reactions in one and a
half hours so that's six thousand
reactions per machine in a 12 hour day
everyone asks you know what's the
sensitivity well we use the FDA approved
primes and probes we look for N1 and N2
it's actually a superplex reaction now
so we put them both together with the
same fluorochrome uh and the using the
the FDA definition for
the sensitivity well we're down to about
12 to 15 copies per microliter of saliva
that's six copies in the actual reaction
so this is similar to sensitivity with
some tests within euas with mp1s it's
not Ultra sensitive but it's certainly
sensitive enough to pick up any
infectious individuals
in terms of uh correlation we were able
to get raw saliva from our Arizona state
they're very good to give us a range of
samples with different cqs and they were
actually screening for orphe b s and n
and you can see there is actually a
fantastic correlation of the CT values
between our tests for N1 and N2 and the
three viral targets that were previously
determined in the ASU
we've developed the campus developed a
good website you can go to this web
thing if you just type in campus ready
Davis it'll give you all the details
uh and and the ongoing
the ongoing record of how many positives
Etc we've got
we have a very rapid turnaround time uh
we're reporting back about 33 percent of
the results get back the same day and 59
the next day so in total that's over 90
percent are reported by the end of the
next day of sampling
this has resulted in Rapid isolation of
infected individuals and quarantine in
close contacts
so going forward
you know it's important to emphasize
that frequent testing is only part of
the mitigation strategy now testing
doesn't solve the problem it just tells
you how much of a problem you have so
wearing masks and limiting personal
contacts are absolutely critical this is
the message that we we propagate out
we're doing so four thousand five
thousand a day regularly we could
probably do eight thousand a day fairly
easily uh though you know the food for
it's large but it's not infinite
we're expanding now we're offering
testing to all the school systems in
yellow County we we help out with
assisted living facilities as well as
doing the city of Davisville and old
campus and we're always aware of
alternative Technologies but in terms of
the cost benefit ratio even the rapid
antigen tests we're going to be very
comfortable in price and so we're then
moving really on to monitoring for new
strengths
just as they'll consider a wrap-up of
this section
it works rate limiting the kiosk the
sample collection these are large this
is not rate limiting the qpcr machine is
not limiting many workflows it's the
analytical component that's that's rate
limiting it is not where we are limited
at the moment is the accessioning step
even though it's RNA extraction free
uh it's a very simple workflow still
just moving
uh thousands of tubes through the lab a
day this is what's rate limiting
blah blah
I would like to point out that this has
been a massive team effort from all
across campus you know we've got 60
staff and 75 students working in the
kiosk we've got three teams two
production and one development in the
testing lab we've got data management
team we've had terrific support from LGC
and Eugene Tech and then never
underestimate the importance of having a
a great Administration behind you all
sorts of aspects of the administrative
components on campus really got behind
this and made it happen
so moving on to the vans
there's a lot of noise in the Press
right now about uh viral variance
the viral evolution is inevitable most
of the sequence variation occurring can
be unconsequential but a few uh changes
increase Fitness and this is what we're
seeing you have effects within infinite
population size continually generating
mutations and testing pinging the human
population selection initially right now
has been for increased transmissibility
and that's what we see in several
strains
as we roll out vaccines you're putting a
steep selection pressure to render the
vaccines less effective increased
violence is probably inevitable and some
predict vaccines will be ineffective
within 12 months what we need to do is
try and minimize boom bust Cycles
vaccines being deployed the virus
evolving to overcome them
we're currently doing really what we're
doing is only practice for when a
variant appears that's not controlled by
vaccines
we need to sort of prepare for that
eventuality now of the new strains that
are here there's the b117 the originally
identified in the UK
b1531 is written identified in South
Africa and P1 that was originally
identified in Brazil or travels from
Brazil and Japan
there are more more infectious probably
because of mutations Than The Binding
site to H2
the data that's coming out says the
vaccines at least uh
they are effective in most of them are
effective in reducing the severe illness
and death what we don't really know so
much about is how well
um the how many of those vaccinated
individuals will be asymptomatic
uh you know we we monitor for variations
in the N1 N2 binding sites and probes
and so far there haven't been any
variants that will compromise the M1 N2
assay
so we we'll now talk about
um
how we're deploying oh yes so there is
evidence though that some of the uh
vaccines uh some some of the variants
have reduced or a complete escape from
neutralizing antibodies and this
particularly the South African uh
originating strain
in terms of the U.S the epidemiology
these strains are here uh you you can
see that they are proliferating the CDC
recently said that the b117
is uh now the predominant strain in many
parts of the US and you can see that the
other ones are beginning to come in and
just recently the so-called double
mutant from India hasn't been officially
declared a variant of concern of
Interest yet but it certainly has
mutations that are in common with some
of these other high transmissible highly
transmissible strains there's the strain
that's proliferating in India
so what are we doing about it well
these mutants have variants have
characteristic mutations often
predominantly in the S protein you can
see the n501y that's common to the three
major variants of concern at the moment
in the interface between the
the H2 receptor and the spike protein
so we can design assays to detect these
mutations now
a lot of it's been done by sequencing
the problem with sequencing is it's
expensive it's slow
and you're generating a lot of redundant
information so you've got to think why
are we
using a particular technology now
sequencing is extremely important
for identifying new variants
however once you've identified variance
the the values and the novel information
content you get from a sequence
decreases asymptotically as the number
of sequences goes up and therefore it's
much better to screen for the
discriminatory Snips it allows you to
get through much higher numbers you get
a rules for picture of
of what variants you have so I've
summarized here we what we're doing is
we're deploying uh genotyping technology
and
actually the intelli cube and the Nexa
were originally designed for detecting
Schnitz so it makes perfect sense to
deploy these machines in this context
you can get high throughput the reagent
cost is lower anything that's PCR able
you can run through these assays the
technical complexity is way lower
and the turnaround importantly is much
faster however the resolution is
relatively low compared with sequencing
and certainly you're not going to
discover de novo snap mutations
furthermore at the end of the day it's
much easier to interpret the data you
get off a genotyping platform than a
sequencing one
so the assay that we're working with
developing collaboration with LGC
uh it's a it's a probe competition
experiment you have probes that are not
fluorescent because they're tagged with
the probe but they also have a quencher
and
until they hybridize to a template and
then the type polymerase goes through
and it's exonuclease activity cleans the
probe releasing the fluorochrome from
the quench uh you then get a signal so
it's a competition of the match and
mismatch that you get will give you your
signal and anyone that's familiar with
this field will see that we've got the
the usual
the usual uh
sites that we're going after and this
pattern then allows you to discriminate
between variants of concern uh and
different variants of Interest
here's an example of qptr trace for the
h69 V70 deletion you clearly see in blue
you've got the wild type clustering
nicely here and then you've got
in red uh five variants clearly have a
different Trace ratio
the fam to CFO fluorochrome
there's actually two types of samples
loaded on this gel woman's Royal saliva
and the others was the residual on a
nasal swab and therefore
they were in the vtn you can see they
have a different Baseline but still we
get a perfectly good signal out of that
sample
here's a summary of endpoint results we
got for a genotype genotyping acids you
can see this very nice discrimination in
blue you've got the fan which is wild
type and the CFO is detecting the
variants in red
for example in the top right panel there
you can see that the l452 r variant
characteristic of the caliber so-called
California variant you know more than 50
percent of this particular sample was
was it the California variant
so to give it an overview
snip assays for variants of of SARS Kobe
2 the high throughput they're rapid
they're inexpensive we're not the only
show in town multiple snip assays from
being developed
anything's PCR able you can run them on
there's no need for RNA extraction which
keeps the price down and speeds things
up so if it is that you do extract RNA
in your primary test sure you can run
that and it gives very good results
it can be run on a PCR machine and the
endpoint assets may actually be
sufficient so that it's it's low-tech
anyone with a PCR machine and a
fluorescent Plate Reader could
uh be analyzing for variants
it allows monitoring for much larger
numbers of samples from sequencing
all samples up to a CQ of at 30 will
give us a good signal and that's about
the same threshold sequencing
and the information can be generated in
real time so it allows them for the
interventions
it does not replace the need for
sequencing it's complementary
it relies on sequencing to identify new
variants of Interest
and also it doesn't compete with the
supply chain sequencing now a big
challenge is it's not a FDA authorized
at the moment and so we need to change
the regulatory landscape to fully
exploit this technology
so ongoing what we're doing we have a
variety of inputs we test both
asymptomatic and symptomatic positives
uh all positives are genotypes at about
14 Loco though some of them were done
that were carrying that down
we can get informative data within a few
days of sample collection
and so all non-wild-tech samples are
sequence validated and the sequencing
takes about a week later
two examples here you know you've got
the reference pattern above and then
we've got two actual samples
and you can see the pattern one matched
b117 the other one was a potential b1351
uh
originally collected
two days later we have the genotyping
done and then it takes another week or
so before the sequence validation so we
were knowing within just a few days of
sample collection that we had a variant
so in terms of relation to uh
surveillance and vaccination
one of the challenges we're now facing
is that people after vaccination are
saying I don't need to be tested anymore
and this is a message that we need to
try and counter it's extremely important
that people after vaccination continue
to get tested uh and you know we know
even with enough with the um the Wild
Side the non-variance you get 40 to 60
percent of infections are asymptomatic
and the efficacy data for vaccines is
how many people get symptoms not how
many people are actually infected
there's very little data on how
frequently that frequently vaccinated
individuals become infected and whether
they're infections to others the CDC a
couple of days ago just uh report
reported that six thousand individuals
have been infected in the US after
vaccination so it's critically important
to monitor the variance that reduce
protection of vaccines
and you know almost inevitably uh we're
going to get variance that compromise
the effectiveness of vaccines and
without testing we're not going to pick
that up
so so taking the global view is
extremely important that uh surveillance
is down on the global level you can't
build walls and keep out the virus uh so
unless we roll out both vaccination and
testing on a global scale we're going to
continually going to have problems
and sequencing just is not feasible in
many countries while the relatively
low-tech genotyping is so it's
complementary and we'll still need to
sequence from uh around the world but we
don't need to do it in the same
intensity that is currently being
proposed in in the US and Europe
a big effort needs to be made for
regulatory acceptance for public health
actions and then ultimately we're going
to have to get Pub FDA approval for
genotyping it by clear labs for patient
interventions so that when a strain uh
that that is more virulent causes
greater pathology comes along we've got
to be able to genotype in real time
sequencing is just way too slow right
now we don't have that in place
so wrapping it up uh we have a
genotyping sequencing team
a lot of efforts going on and I'd like
to predict the also to highlight uh the
design team Lindy mcfan Tanya Nolan at
LTC they've done a great job of
Designing the assays to give them to us
we test them and put them into
production and it's been a a great
win-win collaborations about these
assays
and with that I will finish